did you know that in mr and mrs smith in
the carnival scene jon closes his left
eye to take aim then opens it to retain
peripheral vision before shooting this
is what snipers do hinting at his
proficiency with weapons did you know
that in star wars revenge of the sith as
obi-wan and anakin fight b-1 battle
droids r2d2 helps by tripping one in the
background
did you know that in the truman show as
marlin restocks a vending machine he
starts to remove the candy bars when
truman turns to leave thinking the scene
has ended nobody uses vending machines
on a set where all the food is free
do you know that in impractical joker's
the movie will ferrell makes a cameo
without any lines he just holds a pizza
and moves his mouth like he's eating did
you know that in thor the dark world
when natalie portman couldn't make the
reshoot for the final kiss chris
hemsworth was given a list of women to
take her place instead he chose his wife
who wore natalie's clothes in a wig to
shoot this passionate kiss did you know
that in pirates of the caribbean the
curse of the black pearl most of jack
sparrow's hats are made of rubber
because johnny depp kept losing them
overboard after he lost ten leather hats
the costume designer started making them
out of rubber to float did you know that
in die hard this henchman improvised
stealing a candy bar which assured him a
longer life according to writer stephen
d'souza i was killing somebody every
eight to ten pages but that moment made
him interesting he's one of the last
guys to die
do you know that in harry potter snape's
outfit is the only one to never change
throughout the films according to
costume designer janita meme it was
perfect when something is perfect you
cannot change it she joined in the
prisoner of azkaban and altered the
other costumes to fit the darker tone
did you know that impact to the future
part two the film shares its opening
with the ending of back to the future
but due to jennifer being recast and
four years passing from michael j fox
and christopher lloyd the sequence had
to be completely re-shot for part two
did you know that in joe dirt joe works
for scotch oil which is the name of the
company that chris farley's father had
owned and where chris had worked before
becoming a comedian this is a small
tribute by david to his late friend